foreign
discussion
um it's worth bearing in mind that
Michael's traveled the world reporting
and studying he was in Chernobyl to
report on the disaster there he was then
in Ukraine in 2014 when Crimea kicked
off
um and he's got Ukrainian Heritage as
well Michael let's get stuck straight
into it let's begin with Ukraine looking
forward to what's going to happen next
in the future there I've been quite
struck by The Narrative coming out in
the past couple weeks where
two weeks ago um it seems that the
Ukrainian counter defensive was
completely on the move it was a mini
victory for Ukraine
um contrast that with yesterday where
Putin stood up in Moscow and declared
that he's going to Annex these four
regions
um
where do you think it's going to go next
sure well thank you for having me and
thank you everyone for being here well
look I think right now what we're seeing
is a split screen reality I think you
have a Mr Putin who is increasingly out
of touch with reality who is desperate
essentially because of humiliating
devastating Battlefield losses to the
point where he had to widen the
conscription of men heading towards
Ukraine to 300 000 and that was a very
significant move in the sense that now
basically every area code of Russia is
now going to be impacted in one way or
the other
um and all of us saw the the reaction of
many of the Russians who have
conscription age
they fled or went into hiding
um but I it can't you know and talking
about that speech which was uh you know
out of the pluton Putin Playbook uh
blaming the West for all of the ills
blaming the West for trying to destroy
Russia I think on the one hand he's
trying to whip up domestic support
um get people Russians rallied around
him but uh on the other hand
um I think you know talking about him
being out of touch I don't think he's
recognizing what's actually happening on
the battlefield including today by the
way which there have been even more
significant Ukrainian gains the Russian
defense Ministry admitted a retreat of
Russian forces from basically the same
regions where Mr Putin has announced the
illegal absorption
so um but this was
um the the speech was uh uh to me a
major Crossing of a red line
uh I actually would have expected more
uh in terms of a western reaction
especially from the white house instead
uh Mr Biden and admittedly the West
America rather has done a lot to support
Ukraine in terms of funding in terms of
Weaponry in terms of ammunition in terms
of training in terms of satellite
intelligence that sort of thing but just
uh widening the sanctions saying that
we're going to Target people at the
central bank or people on put in circle
I don't think that is much of a
deterrent for Mr Putin
um I think I might maybe jumping ahead
of myself but I think there was a
question about what we should learn from
recent history
um I think Mr Putin still lives in 2014
where he illegally annexed Crimea and
his russian-backed thugs invaded uh the
donbass and I was there when that was
happening and not much of a finger was
lifted by the West so I think he still
feels that he can get away with these
things and you know I end this with one
major point is that the only thing thugs
or dictators respond to is strength and
we're not seeing enough at the moment
and so I mean in terms of I suppose the
Western response then
how far should the West Go I mean
obviously at the moment we're seeing
huge energy price increases over here in
Britain and across the West in general
as a response to the conflict going on
how far should governments be pushing it
when they're responding do you think and
how far do you think they will go which
I suppose is the next well I guess the
luxuries that uh Vladimir Putin and
people like Xi Jinping have is they
don't have to face an electric every
year or every few years you know value
become leader for life and I think as I
write in the book dictators learn from
each other and they follow each other
um but I I think um if I can answer it
this way what we probably should have
done to help prevent this and um one
thing is I don't think uh the West
anticipated what Mr Putin would do
earlier this year in February and there
were a lot of flashing red lights well
ahead of time of the full scale Invasion
one of them was that rambling uh 5000
word article
um from July 12th of last year called on
the historical Unity of Russians and
ukrainians where Mr Putin basically
argued that ukrainians and Russians are
one people that these are traditionally
Russian lands well that's not true but
uh I think this was
um a call to to battle about a call to
war and then I think the other big
flashing red light that the West uh
didn't react to earlier enough was that
remember that months-long build up of
Russian forces and Russian army along
the borders of Ukraine including Avila
Russia
the other uh so just what do you think
that we should have done then I think
well for example what should have been
done is the training the supply of
Weaponry the supply of ammunition should
have happened a lot earlier I think it's
not only I'm not only going to point the
finger at the White House or the LSA
palace in Paris I'm also going to and
I've said this publicly the United
Nations system the humanitarian AIDS Aid
agencies was woefully unprepared up
until the lead up of you know the
invasion I mean I was receiving calls
from New York U.N headquarters asking me
if I thought the war was going to happen
I said for sure what happened and yet
they did not pre-position people and
they did not pre-position supplies and
this is a really important point because
for example the world food program which
is basically the the FedEx of the Aid
System uh was scrambling after the
invasion started to get crucial
life-saving supplies inside Ukraine uh
who the same thing and the other thing
that got really angered people like me
including
former colleagues of mine who still work
in the U.N system is that it took weeks
before the Secretary General of the
sorry the director general of who or the
executive executive director of Unicef
could use the r word and say it was
Russia that invaded they couldn't even
utter the word Russia in their official
statements fearing that it might you
know spark some kind of reaction from
Russia so there were a lot of mistakes I
think on a number of areas and then
again the sanctions issue they should
have been implemented beforehand as the
ukrainians were begging to act more as a
deterrent because as we're now finding
sanctions take a long time to take hold
to make an impact uh as I said last
night on another panel I'm not an
advocate of sanctions being used to hurt
the common man because eventually these
trickle down and often hurt the most
vulnerable but they have been used I
think in the past as a deterrent and I
think they're just implemented too late
so so looking forward then
um so we've looked I suppose we've
looked at what the mistakes are made
um you know 18 months or so ago looking
forward
to you know ending this conflict I mean
do you see that on the horizon
um and if not how do how do you think we
get there
sadly
um I think this is going to take us well
into next year I think it's going to be
a very difficult winter uh not only for
you all but you know higher energy bills
things like that but also for the
Ukrainian people
um we're hoping that uh the long range
forecasts are correct that it's going to
be a mild winter but with the Russians
going about and deliberately destroying
civilian infrastructure for example in
East in many parts of Ukraine the
heating systems are actually the
Distribution Systems are actually above
ground so they're very vulnerable to
attack so we have to do everything
possible on one hand the humanitarian
side make sure that ukrainians can get
as much
equipment available as possible to heat
their homes warm clothing things like
that but on the um standing up to
Russia's side I think we have to
continue with the training the provision
of high-tech weapons and ammunition
ukrainians tell me they need a lot more
tanks they need a lot a lot more
helicopters the one thing that I have
been evangelizing about from day one is
to give the ukrainians the ability to
protect their own Skies now I'm not
necessarily talking about a no-fly zone
that is something the West is not
prepared to do but for as long as the
Russians have this huge stockpile of
long range weapons the sort that can fly
at very high altitude a very high speed
and very long distances all the way to
the Ukrainian Polish border places like
liov Odessa where I'm now based no inch
of Ukraine can be considered safe I
think that behind the scenes the U.S
Administration is provisioning the
ukrainians with quite high-tech
technology that they're able to fire at
these missiles and bring them down
before they strike I understand for
example Kiev will be protected more or
less with the same technology that
protects Washington DC that's pretty hot
stuff
um but the at the moment
um for example if six Russian missiles
are headed towards Odessa the ukrainians
have the ability on average to bring
down above four of them but what they
really want is something like the Iron
Dome system I I suppose I mean the one
weapon which you haven't mentioned
um is you know nuclear weapons yeah and
you talk about in your book you talk
about Chernobyl moments and you talk
about covered being one of those which
you know changes fundamentally changes
um you know the way that Society
operates and how we view defense
um what do you think the likelihood of
Putin resorting to that nuclear weapon
might be and also I suppose presumably
looking forward
um if that's something that we don't
want we have to be aware of that in our
Western response as well yeah
I think we should um hope for the best
but prepare for the worst
um you mentioned Chernobyl um I think it
was uh you know what we're seeing is
history repeating itself whether it's
the
um using of the zapore Asia nuclear
power plant as a weapon or the stealing
of grain or the forced uh uh deportation
of ukrainians to remote parts of Russia
this has all happened in Ukraine's past
modern history we saw in 1986 with the
Chernobyl nuclear disaster that a lot of
this was done out of sheer stupidity and
carelessness
uh it it all goes the mind it really
boggles the mind to think that the
Russians returned to Chernobyl in
February March occupied it and started
doing things like digging up
contaminated soil and spreading it uh
taking over the control rooms and
telling the Ukrainian staff there what
to do and then what do they do they do
the same thing with these nuclear power
plant which by the way is the largest in
Europe and just uh in the past 24 hours
we've heard of the head of that plant
being uh detained but for weeks now the
staff there have been working under very
very difficult conditions
um we are we they Russians have parked
their vehicles I mentioned there we are
headed we have been headed very very
close to a disaster there in terms of
your your question about the nuclear
weapons I don't think we can exclude
that from Mr Putin's Reigns of ranges of
options he has threatened to use them
um I I actually don't think he's
bluffing uh but I I think I'm more a
bigger likelihood would be
for him to use chemical and biological
weapons
um against civilian populations why do I
think that is because just look at what
they've done to cities like mariopol or
to kharkiv or just in the past 48 Hours
the deliberate targeting of uh civilian
Convoy I think it's now 28 killed in
that one
um as soon as we've seen we thought
we've seen the basement of Russian
inhumanity to man they tend to surprise
us in doing even worse so one more point
on this I think what they would do is
make it look like an accident maybe a
chemical or biological leak plausible
deniability and then say it wasn't our
fault but it causes huge harm because
presumably if that happens I mean Putin
will know that
there would be an enhanced Western
response
um and you know let's say he there's a
chemical accident
um that the West isn't going to buy just
in the way the same way that I suppose
the West hasn't bought these Sham
referendums in the East
um he knows that the West would step up
their support of Ukraine which is
something that you can't afford so I
mean do you really think that he would
risk that
um I think uh zooming out and generally
speaking uh when the West does not make
clear what its red lines are as
it was in Syria with a chemical weapons
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas